y
[Música]
las tropas de moscú avanzan en el este
ucraniano controlando cada vez más
territorio soberanía es que está bajo
bombardeos constantes y los pro rusos
afirman que ya se tomaron alemán aunque
el ministerio de defensa ucraniano
sostiene que allí todavía resiste en
algunos distritos
la iglesia católica de italia
investigará los abusos sexuales que
cometieron los clérigos en los últimos
dos años mientras que sólo harán un
análisis de los casos reportados desde
el 2000 víctimas y activistas mostraron
su descontento con una protesta en el
vaticano
la asociación nacional del rifle de eeuu
celebrará su reunión anual este viernes
y sábado el evento se realizará en texas
el mismo estado donde un tiroteo masivo
dejó 21 muertos en una escuela en wilde
y tenemos reporte desde esta ciudad
bienvenidos a france 24 estas son las
noticias internacionales y mi nombre es
maría clara calle empezamos con la
actualidad ucraniana las tropas rusas
han logrado el mayor avance en semanas y
cada vez golpean más fuerte de las
ciudades que siguen en pie en la región
del donbass los militares de moscú
tienen a la urbe de severodonezk rodeada
según el alcalde de la ciudad al menos
un 60% de los edificios residenciales
han sido destruidos y mil quinientas
personas han muerto desde el inicio de
la guerra cerca de 13.000 habitantes
permanecen dentro de esta ciudad una de
las pocas de la provincia del lugar que
no ha caído más al oeste los rusos están
a punto de tomarse la ciudad ferroviaria
del imán a los prorrusos dicen que ya
está totalmente bajo su poder
inicialmente un portavoz de la
presidencia ucraniana afirmó lo mismo
pero luego el ministerio de defensa
sostuvo que hay algunos distritos que
resisten en dirección al imán los
defensores ucranianos están
contrarrestando los intentos del enemigo
de empujar a nuestras tropas desde las
partes noroeste y sureste del imán y
presionar un avance sobre slomianski
en medio de los intensos combates en el
donbass todos los días las compañías de
ferrocarriles ucranianos evacuen a los
civiles de la región en sus trenes y sin
cobrarles el tiquete un equipo de france
24 está en la zona y nos cuenta cómo
avanza este proceso
en un tren que viaja hacia el este
alexander imparte un curso de primeros
auxilios
los participantes son tubos empleados
ferroviarios ucranianos en misión
humanitaria
desde el comienzo de la invasión hemos
estado evacuando a los civiles hacia el
oeste hoy vamos a ir a pop rock para
sacar a la gente y darles comida agua y
asistencia médica si la necesita
los voluntarios y los miembros de las
ong están llevando a los refugiados de
todo el donbass a la estación de tren de
pop-rock pero hoy los bombardeos han
bloqueado el acceso a algunas zonas el
tren parte con 101 refugiados a bordo
mucho menos de los habituales esculcando
morales que trajeron el mayor número
posible de personas de los lugares que
podían llegar tarde y productiva
como casi todo el mundo aquí luzmila y
su madre no querían irse
como mi madre es discapacitada y se
organizó todo en casa fue muy complicado
y quién quiere irse de todos modos nadie
quiere salir de su casa el voto mamá
tenía resultó herido en una explosión
en bicicleta cuando un mortero cayó
cerca
y un mes después su casa fue atacada los
voluntarios le convencieron de que se
fuera
nunca he visto un minibús ir tan rápido
eso es porque hubo disparos a lo largo
de nuestra ruta y no cualquier fuego
fuego de artillería
[Música]
más adelante alexander se reencuentra
con una familia de su ciudad natal a
bach mod y se ha vuelto mucho más
intenso los combates de 2014 fueron un
juego de niños comparados con esto
he oído que los rusos querían tomar
ucrania en tres días bueno es un
completo fracaso
no
vamos a ganar esta es la continuación de
las guerras de independencia que
libraron nuestros antepasados y
llegaremos hasta el final estamos unidos
saldremos victoriosos gracias
los padres de alexandr siguen en back
moore uno de los principales objetivos
de los rusos todavía no han conseguido
convencerles de que evacúen
rusia también controla parte del sur
ucraniano especialmente las salidas al
mar el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
cell es que denunció que moscú bloqueó
el acceso a los puertos del mar negro y
ya tiene el control en el mar de azov
después de tomarse mariupol según el
mandatario la consecuencia es que las
rutas comerciales ucranianas están
cerradas y no ha podido exportar 22
millones de toneladas de granos y así
rusia presiona a través de los alimentos
creo que rusia ha apostado a liberada
mente la crisis alimentaria para
aumentar la dependencia de otros países
sobre sí mismos y hacer el acceso a los
alimentos otro factor de presión
presiona la política global cuanto antes
se liberen nuestras tierras de los
ocupantes más seguras de hecho será la
protección de las personas en todo el
mundo
deseos agresivos de aquellos que quieren
seguir políticas coloniales como en los
viejos tiempos
julien jousse y moscú pagará en rublos
por el uso de las patentes de los países
a los que considera inamistosos según la
disposición que firmó este viernes el
presidente vladimir putin la medida
aplicará para las producciones de más de
45 países incluidos eeuu y los miembros
de la unión europea desde la capital
rusa nuestro corresponsal xavier colás
tiene los detalles
y el presidente ruso vladimir putin ha
afirmado una orden que permitirá a los
rusos ya las compañías rusas pagar las
patentes los derechos de propiedad
intelectual en rublos la medida afecta a
unos 45 países son los países domina
denominados por el gobierno ruso como
países inamistosos a aquellos como por
ejemplo la unión europea eeuu o reino
unido que han impuesto sanciones a rusia
por sus operaciones en ucrania y también
aquellos países ha explicado el jefe de
estado ruso que han desacreditado
informativamente a las fuerzas armadas
rusas por las actividades del ejército
ruso en ucrania se trata de una medida
unilateral a la que se tengan que
amoldar estos países si quieren cobrar
la propiedad intelectual tendrán que
abrir cuentas en rublos para cobrar las
también ha sido muy duro por cierto el
ministro de asuntos exteriores ruso
serguéi lávrov que ha criticado una
cruzada mundial contra todo lo ruso que
afecta según lávrov a la cultura a
artistas como tchaikovsky o 23 que que
están siendo según la broma ahora mismo
cancelados
en otras noticias el g7 se trazó una
nueva meta ambiental descarbonizar el
sector eléctrico para el año 2035 esto
implica que los siete países miembros
deben eliminar gradualmente el carbón a
más tardar en 2030 con el propósito de
reducir las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero desde berlín donde se reúnen
los ministros de las naciones del g7
también anunciaron que los vehículos
eléctricos dominarían las ventas de
automóviles nuevos para fines de la
década
y reflexión que indican word y testeos
siempre habrá calentamiento global
todavía puede ser posible para nosotros
arreglar los errores del pasado es
imposible para nosotros deshacer los el
calentamiento global cero ya no es una
opción la única cuestión que estamos
discutiendo aquí es se frenará el
calentamiento global mediante una acción
política decisiva en los próximos años y
no en los próximos 30 años sino en los
próximos 4 5 8 10 años de tal manera que
entonces tengamos siquiera opción de
acción su avatar james mutismo ante sus
sets activistas contra los abusos
sexuales protestaron en el vaticano para
exigirle a la iglesia católica que actúe
en las investigaciones de estos crímenes
y es que después de una semana de
reuniones los obispos católicos de
italia anunciaron que encargaran un
informe sobre los abusos sexuales que
cometieron los clérigos únicamente en
los últimos dos años mientras que los
casos que van del 2000 al 2021 sólo
tendrán un análisis según informó el
cardenal mateo zuppi los grupos de
víctimas expresaron su frustración
ellos pedían una investigación
independiente general que se remontará
al menos a una parte del siglo pasado
como hicieron en francia y en alemania
l acción esto nos moviliza
estamos aquí por la inmovilidad de la
iglesia pero sobre todo porque el estado
no interviene por alguna razón parece
que el estado está dejando que la
iglesia maneje la situación la
contradicción de esto es que la iglesia
es técnicamente la parte acusada la
parte que se supone que debe reparar los
abusos sexuales del clero
necesitamos un organismo imparcial en
este caso el estado para manejar la
situación
en cambio el estado ha sido la única
parte importante ausente en todo este
asunto desde hace años único grandes
ente disputa cuesta problemática donald
adam pasamos a noticias de américa la
asociación nacional del rifle de eeuu
inauguró este viernes su reunión anual
en houston texas el mismo estado en
donde el pasado martes hubo el tiroteo
más mortífero que ha habido en una
escuela del país en casi una década
varios republicanos y hasta el ex
presidente de donald trump asistirán al
evento a pesar del debate nacional que
se revivió tras la matanza de 21
personas en ubaldi conectamos con
cristóbal vázquez nuestro enviado
especial a esta ciudad cristóbal
bienvenido y a propósito de la
convención cuéntanos qué vas hoy y
mañana injusto
así
estarán los líderes republicanos más
importantes más conservadores entre
ellos el ex presidente de donald trump
que hace tres años no asiste a esta
convención de la asociación nacional del
rifle hace dos hace 3 años tampoco se
celebra este evento precisamente por el
tema del cob y está llamado la atención
que han han han dicho que no asistirán
varios varias figuras republicanas
importantes precisamente después de lo
que ocurrió en balde músicos también han
cancelado su asistencia y varios
gobernadores han cancelado la existencia
sin embargo pues el argumento principal
de este evento en houston que termina el
29 de este mes es precisamente que la
gente más armada puede proveer más
seguridad a colegios y lugares públicos
sin embargo es de resaltar que muchas
preguntas ayer se hicieron en la rueda
de prensa en igual de sobre por qué la
policía bastante armada estuvo casi una
hora afuera del colegio sin hacer algo
para detener al atacante y hablamos de
los vínculos políticos y la influencia
de la asociación nacional del rifle que
funcionarios estarán el evento y cuáles
son los senadores que más dinero reciben
de esta organización
el senador por texas es muy polémico a
nivel nacional es el que más recibe
dinero por parte de las empresas de
armas en eeuu y el lobby de armas que es
uno de los más grandes en este país
estarán también el gobernador de dakota
del sur
kristi noem y la gobernadora de el
gobernador perdón de carolina del norte
también marca eurovisión y estará
obviamente donald trump es de resaltar
que en balde llegará el domingo el
presidente jobvite en estar acompañando
a las víctimas se hará una rueda de
prensa también en esa ciudad y pues en
los funerales las empresas funerarias
han dicho públicamente que no van a
cobrarle a las familias de las víctimas
de balde precisamente después de este
tiroteo que deja 19 niños muertos y dos
profesores también gracias cristóbal por
toda esta información
y en más noticias de eeuu hoy finaliza
un juicio muy seguido el de johnny depp
y su ex-esposa amber heard en un caso de
difamación en medio de denuncias mutuas
de violencia doméstica mientras que el
actor de piratas del caribe afirma que
ayer le lanzó una botella que casi le
hace perder un dedo ella sostiene que
fue violada por su expareja y que a raíz
de las audiencias la están amenazando
esta mañana a los abogados de las partes
entregan los argumentos finales para que
el jurado delibere y entregue un
veredicto en el proceso
se acerca el final del caso que enfrenta
la ex pareja de actores johnny depp
umbert a quien él denunció por
difamación por un valor de 50 millones
de dólares a finales de 2018 la actriz
dijo en la prensa a ser una víctima de
violencias conyugales aunque no mencionó
a depp el rechazo claras referencias a
su relación no vimos ningún ser humano
es perfecto ciertamente ninguno de
nosotros pero nunca en mi vida he
cometido agresión sexual abuso físico
todas estas historias son extravagantes
y escandalosas
durante seis semanas los abogados
llamaron al estrado a los artistas así
como a expertos y testigos que hablaron
de la intimidad del matrimonio que duró
entre 2015 y 2017 y retrataron una
relación tóxica entre las pruebas hay
fotos de la droga consumida por johnny
depp y que dan cuenta de su adicción al
alcohol que según la actriz lo volvieron
violento en calidad de denunciado aun
bayern también atacó a su ex esposo y lo
oculta del mundo por 100 millones de
dólares declaró con imágenes que fue
golpeada por él
era el amor de mi vida y lo era pero
también era esta otra cosa y la otra
cosa horrible ofogo afirmó además que
fue violada lo que diego evocando por el
contrario una pelea que le dejó con un
dedo parcialmente mutilado
supuestamente porque ella le arrojó una
botella
la señora hertz en su frustración y en
su rabia en su cólera ella golpearía
ella podía empezar con una bofetada
podía empezar con un en polvo
de lo que se trata esta conversación es
la disparidad la disparidad entre johnny
y yo en nuestras peleas físicas la
disparidad de como él me golpeaba
proactivamente y yo tenía que recurrir a
golpearlo reactivamente reactive hearing
mientras se emite una sentencia sus
carreras están en pausa y ambos alegan
pérdidas millonarias mientras se espera
que este proceso marque un precedente en
violencia doméstica
así llegamos al final de las noticias
los invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24
[Música]